hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remembered so you don't have to let's
talk about whitewashing stop obviously
this is a subject everybody has a strong
opinion on especially given the news
recently two big movies have just done
previews a trailer from Marvel's Doctor
Strange and is still from Paramount's
remake of ghost in the shell' the
internet flipped as both films were
accused of whitewashing which for those
who don't know is one a person who's
supposed to be of a certain ethnicity is
suddenly played by a white person in
ghost in the shells case people were
upset because Scarlett Johansson was
playing what was originally an Asian
character and in dr. Strange's case a
Tibetan man is not being portrayed as a
Celtic woman played by Tilda Swinton
this is a touchy subject that's making a
lot of people feel enraged whitewashing
is an art that let's face it white
people have mastered bullshitting for
years which is all the more reason to
get upset people can't believe that
still going on is America home to so
many different cultures and races still
resorting to the same offensive tricks
have things really gotten better or have
we just disguised our hypocrisy even
more well for ghost in the shell'
originally a Japanese property there is
one group of people that for the most
part doesn't seem to have that big a
problem the Japanese Granta we obviously
can't speak for all of them but when
asking random Japanese people on the
street what they thought the casting of
the film most of them seemed pretty okay
not only did they say she looked like
the character but they also knew it was
an American film and American films have
mostly white actors I guess in hindsight
if Japan did their version of say
Superman and they cast a Japanese actor
in the role Americans probably wouldn't
care I think most people are assuming
too that because the film is made by
Americans it probably wouldn't take
place in Japan the same way the ring or
The Grudge where Asian properties but
clearly weren't filmed in Asia and
didn't star agent people or the same way
they remade Seven Samurai in the Old
West the first time in fact there's tons
of remakes of foreign films that have
done this as well as replace the actors
with white Americans but it
never gotten criticized even to this day
so why is this one getting so beaten up
well there could be a couple reasons
one could be the character struck such a
chord with anime fans that the identity
was so tied toward Japanese heritage or
most likely to America has so many Asian
American actors some of which are even
featured in the film that it seems
pointlessly silly not to cast one in the
leading role they are still after all
Americans I also keep hearing that
there's no Asian American actors big
enough to guarantee a good box office
first of all there's tons of Asian
American actors and many of them are
very successful but I know what they
mean when they say none of them are as
big as Scarlett Johansson sure star
power is important but guess what some
of the highest-grossing movies and
franchises don't have huge names as the
main characters who've heard of Daniel
Radcliffe before Harry Potter who heard
of Christopher Reeve before Superman
most of the names in Avatar in that huge
Harrison who star what bomb but what
about dr. Strange's case is there really
a bias against Tibetan actors well yes
but not in the way that you think you
see 18 percent of Marvel's motion
picture income stems from China and
guess who China is not exactly the
biggest fan of direct so the choice was
made to change the character so much
from a male too bent into a Celtic
female that hopefully it would be so
different that nobody would notice you
have totally underestimated your geeky
fan base we get upset when a
good-looking white man plays a
good-looking white man on the one hand
it's good to know that the American
filmmakers don't have any real anti
Tibetan agenda I mean they're a business
and they wanna make as much money as
they can but on the other hand it's
still ethically wrong they're putting a
prejudice ahead of not making more money
but let's be honest this happens a lot
in business like all the time and let's
also be honest we've let very similar
choices slide recently Oh what you mean
blackface or that slanty-eyed makeup
that never fooled anyone come on that's
that's the generation before us that
stuff is but you've been ok with a lot
more than you think
in fact we've grown up with it mostly in
cartoons
appoo and dr. Hibbert white guy aladdin
and Jasmine white people
hey you remember all those anime
starring Japanese people practically all
of them are redubbed by white Americans
in fact there was even a cowboy bebop
movie in the worst for a while that was
going to start Keanu Reeves and people
were actually excited about it wait a
minute
how come this gets a pass but Scarlett
Johansson doesn't but it doesn't stop
there Belle's not French Tina's not a
girl Tommy's not a boy
Neil Patrick Harris isn't straight rebel
liam's isn't gay that's speaking of
comedies I don't think the cast of Life
of Brian are actually Israeli in fact
Britain and a lot of other countries
have posed as us a lot some of our most
famous American roles are played by
actors who are not American and it even
works the other way around
performers like Alfred Molina or Rama
mafia they've played almost every
ethnicity there is because they look
like almost every ethnicity there is in
fact something that's giving a lot of
praises when a role that's meant for a
white actor is suddenly being played by
a person of color and I know what you
might be saying how is a person of color
playing a white person's role any
different from a white person playing a
person of colors roles
I'm not going rethink I'm going the
answer is obvious because of the
whitewashing we've had in the past
America clearly hasn't had the best
record in terms of treating people
equally and it's obvious there has been
years of keeping women foreigners and
anybody of color as somehow lower than
white men in both society and our media
because of this we're more open to
allowing the gender or race of what was
a white male changed to reflect the
growing environment but even taking race
out of it there's tons of similar
whitewashing going on that we've just
allowed I was actually shocked when they
did lure the rings and they didn't hire
little people for the job now don't get
me wrong the actors were all great I had
no problem with their performances but
the only time little people were used is
when you saw the back of
their heads why are we okay with that
they can play supporting munchkins or
elles but starring roles was asking too
much there's plenty of actors who are
little people and it's not like these
were gigantic names I mean nobody a seal
or the Rings because it started Elijah
Wood they're gonna see it cuz its lore
the Rings
this is still a very similar form of
whitewashing height washing
copyright you probably don't think this
is a big deal but we kept to this exact
way of doing things we wouldn't have the
31 flavors of kick-ass that is Peter
Dinklage this guy is so popular now that
they're writing him in roles that
weren't even meant for a little person
if you were to recast Peter Dinklage his
role on Game of Thrones would say David
Tennant on his knees even though that's
a brilliant actor people would be
offended to no end
we love Peter Dinklage and the idea now
of putting someone like David Tennant in
there would be insulting in bad taste
can't we just give the Hobbit trilogy
millions of dollars and complained about
differences from the book rather than
the fact that we're spending God knows
how much to have people walk on their
knees and do optical illusions because
we just didn't put a real little person
in there however as much as those
prejudices seem really worthy of anger
it's hard to tell where to draw the line
more trans gender roles are opening up
not all of them played by real
transgenders though many say they should
be well okay I guess that seems legit
but there's also deaf roles out there
and shouldn't they be played by real
deaf actors gives us a good point Marlee
Matlin won an Oscar and she's deaf how
about Jamie Foxx and Ray in fact most
blind roles shouldn't they be played by
real blind people I yeah how many blind
actors are there how about switching out
Gary Sinise and Forrest Gump with a
person who doesn't actually have legs
that seems like a very narrow field mr.
garrison on South Park is a game man who
had a sex change and turned lesbian
shouldn't she be represented by an actor
who is the exact same thing
on occasion I think you just gotta act
again it's not always easy to figure out
what's gonna be crossing an ethical line
there's no rulebook for this kind of
stuff and the world is constantly
changing and it's not always easy to
know what's acceptable or not acceptable
and by how many a small minority the
mass majority or does that even matter
the best way I can think to deal with it
is treat it similar to when we cast
adults as children would we prefer
children yes but we also understand
shall labor laws the fact that they grow
up and their voices change so we're not
as hard on people as an adult steps and
to voice them but really we could be if
we wanted to there's lots of child
actors out there looking for work so
it's this like a prejudice against
children by now you're probably figuring
out that whitewashing height washing
gender washing whatever your load of
closes it's all kind of selective I love
a lot of these performances and actors
even if they're not technically what the
character is supposed to be
we love to point to our slippery slopes
and say this will lead to everyone
getting offended by anyone pretending to
be something else or the slippery slope
that white people will be playing all
roles until the end of our days I don't
think either will happen because that
line were apparently never supposed to
cross has never fully been drawn there's
pros and cons we can see past race and
gender and open our minds to a good
performance but we can also feel really
uncomfortable when someone can't see
what they're doing can be really harmful
maybe it all comes down to intent but
even that seems kind of blurred though
Trotsky's did a movie about
reincarnation called Cloud Atlas where
every person plays every gender and
ethnicity you can imagine people are
still on the fence about whether this is
brilliant or amazingly uncomfortable or
even coherent but that's a different
matter it's made even more interesting
though seeing how both directors have
come out as transgender women so to
their credit if any famous directors
know anything about living in another
body it's these two but what if other
transgender people or ethnicities are
still offended by what they do is it
suddenly nonsense have we just made
these two the official voice on the
subject again there's no
clear answer with that said it seems
very unlikely that the makers of ghost
in the shell' are doctors trains we're
trying to push any pro-white agenda
people making these kind of movies hate
bad press and they don't want that kind
of bad press attached they probably just
thought of all the other times people
were okay with it especially just in the
last couple of years and decided if I
probably be okay with it this time -
that doesn't make the issue go away but
if you want people to be fair and open
to what the problem is you also have to
be fair and open to what caused it so
what exactly am I saying we should be
okay with roles played by white people
even though they're not meant for white
people hell no this is America
a growing hodgepodge of variety and
diversity and we should explore it as
much as we can if you see a problem
where those possibilities are being
limited bring them up we deserve to see
every opportunity that can be made
available to us I guess what I'm saying
is don't act like you've never been
guilty of it because we all have we're
trying to get better and we're trying to
see things from a reasonable point of
view but nobody is perfect and nobody is
going to accurately represent
everybody's feelings on everything we've
all overlooked things for our benefit
whether it be in media or even in real
life we know we should do better and
we're trying to do better but we can't
act like our acceptance of it in the
past hasn't somehow played a part to all
of this still happening it's not likely
either of these movies want bad press so
letting them know our concerns will
certainly help change in the future
the sad fact is relations with anybody
different is always going to be a
complicated issue even if we don't want
it to be and with so many in America
celebrating the growth of limitation and
disinterest in variety it looks like
it's gonna stay complicated for a while
all we can do in media is make people
aware of even more opportunities without
claiming that we're higher than them for
noticing it because clearly we don't
notice everything we do let things slide
and not always for the right reason all
we can do is try our best and encourage
others to try their best
in a country that's still 63% white
people chances are they're still gonna
be whitewashing in the near future and
bring up the mistakes that you see but
always remember you probably made them
at some point too and if we want human
beings to change you have to acknowledge
that you yourself are a human being
well that was uncomfortable um boogers
remember so you don't have coming next
week it's the film that brought 3d back
to the cinemas even if you didn't want
it to be its Spy Kids 3d game over but
you can see it now under vessels ad free
early access just three dollars a month
to see tons of people's videos early as
well as a bunch of other extra features
check it out and get the early scoop
hey this is dog walker doing the charity
shout out you want help out with a
charity that Maura Wilson is a part of
of course you do
this is project you are okay this is a
nonprofit organization whose mission is
to create a catalog of accessible funny
meaningful videos for teen struggling
with mental health issues done by adults
who have been there before
in doing so they provide practical
assistance but also and perhaps more
importantly a sense of comfort belonging
and hope there's a ton of videos you can
check out done by a variety of people
you can either donate to their cause
watch and get some helpful information
for a possible problem you might have or
even make a video yeah you can help by
giving advice on something that was
tough to go through but you survived and
can help others to live with Maura
Wilson did one about OCD and depression
Wil Wheaton did one about anxiety the
list goes on it's a really cool creative
idea with a bunch of various ways that
you can contribute click on their site
order YouTube page to see how you can be
helped or you can help out yourself show
your support and share some wisdom